- [Announcer] Vladimir
Vladimirovich Putin.
- [Narrator] For more than two decades,
the Russian president
has been cultivating a strong man image.
(man falling)
He's a judo master
who rides horses, swims
in a Siberian river
and scores goals in hockey
against world champions.
(Vladimir clearing his throat)
But in the past few months,
that image has been challenged.
(Vladimir clearing his throat)
Recent footage of the 69-year-old leader
showed him coughing,
puffy faced or walking
with a stiff right arm,
fueling speculation and questions
from the media about his health
after two years of pandemic isolation.
In late July, intelligence officers
shared their assessments.
- There's lots of rumors
and as far as we can tell,
he's entirely too healthy.
(Vladimir clearing his throat)
- [Narrator] And the
Kremlin has repeatedly said
he's doing well.
(Dmitry speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] So amid the war in Ukraine,
here's why Putin's every public appearance
is being so closely scrutinized.
First, consider that we're
getting very little information
from Russia on the president's well-being.
- Good afternoon, everybody.
- [Narrator] Unlike the White House
that shares regular health
updates for US leaders.
- President Biden is currently
experiencing mild symptoms.
- [Narrator] The Kremlin
is very tight lipped
on the matter.
(lively music)
So videos of a seemingly
tired Putin sitting
at the Victory Day Parade
or holding the table with both hands
during this televised update
about the war in Ukraine,
(Vladimir clearing his throat)
prompted comments by officials
and news outlets around the
world about his fitness.
A top Ukrainian official told a TV channel
that the Russian leader was sick.
(Kyrylo speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] A Newsweek report claiming
that American spies believed Putin
had been treated for
cancer was widely covered.
So journalists have been asking
Russian officials about it.
(journalist speaking in foreign language)
(Sergei speaking in foreign language)
(cameras clicking)
- [Narrator] The Wall Street Journal
couldn't independently
confirm those reports
and the leader of a
European country told us
he believed Putin was healthy.
Still, observers noticed that
when Putin landed in Tehran,
he seemed to walk stiffly
with his right arm hanging unnaturally.
(Vladimir clearing his throat)
He also repeated coughed
and cleared his throat
during and after this trip,
so much so that he spoke about it himself.
(Vladimir speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] It's obviously
hard to draw any conclusion
from this type of footage
but it puts Putin's
health in the spotlight,
even making it a talking point
at a major Security Forum
and prompting Western
intelligence chiefs to weigh in.
- There's no evidence
that Putin is suffering
from serious ill health.
(Vladimir speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] What footage
from the past couple
of years does show clearly
is that the Russian leader appears
to take his physical well-being seriously.
That's what these extremely
long meeting tables suggest.
In the early days of the pandemic,
Putin went into isolation in
his residence outside Moscow.
During two years, he mostly communicated
with the outside world via video calls,
like most leaders around the world.
But even after he started
attending more in-person events
during Russia's war with Ukraine,
most of the time, the public
has been kept at a distance.
The same goes for
officials and world leaders
who've often been seated
far away from him.
This 16-feet-long table
was seen several times,
during Putin's meeting with
France's Emmanuel Macron
and Germany's Olaf Scholz, among others.
The Kremlin said it was keeping in place
all the safety measures
to protect the president
from the coronavirus.
The health of world leaders
is always a matter of public concern.
False reports recently claimed
that the Ukrainian president
was in intensive care, for example.
(people cheering)
But for Russia, heightened scrutiny
of Putin's health also brings questions
about how the country would be governed
without its authoritative leader
at a time when he's at the
center of global politics
over the invasion of Ukraine.
For decades, Moscow has worked hard
to create an aura around one man
as the country's main decision maker
who's believed to directly approve
almost all executive government decisions.
The Kremlin said that Putin's
decision-making powers
are limited by the Russian constitution,
and the president's spokesman
has previously said Moscow
isn't looking for a successor,
and that means any contingency plan
will likely remain a closely held secret.
(dramatic music)